i'm really excited to be here today to
talk to you about some of the work i've
been doing during my phd which has been
around virtual reality
virtual reality or vr has been around
for a long time but only in the past
five to ten years has it really taken
off
all the advances in the graphics the
field of view the tracking technology
have now led us to having commercial vr
headsets which makes this time a really
exciting time to be doing this type of
research
there are a lot of applications for vr
beyond just gaming for example you can
experience what it's like
to
for example go on the international
space station and have new experiences
that you couldn't have otherwise
you can create new artifacts one of my
favorite applications is 3d modeling in
vr it makes a lot of sense to create a
3d object in a 3d environment instead of
trying to map that onto a 2d display
assuming you have good interactions and
interfaces
and finally there are a lot of learning
opportunities in vr that really take
advantage of our innate spatial
reasoning skills here i'm showing an
example of
exploring a 3d molecular structure but
there are a lot of examples of training
simulations for different fields as well
but when we think about what the person
the user is experiencing in these
applications
visually they're seeing a lot of
exciting content but in terms of what
they're doing with their hands at best
they're holding a controller like this
that once in a while vibrates in their
hand so there's really a gap in how much
haptic rendering we're able to do in
commercial vr hardwares today
but when we think about how we interact
in the physical world with physical
objects when we trace a surface we feel
its texture when we grasp an object we
feel its stiffness its weight and all of
these haptic feedback and tactile
feedback that we receive inform how we
improvise in our interactions and how we
manipulate objects
but in vr when we put on the vr headset
we see some virtual content if we reach
out to touch that object there's nothing
really there for us to feel so this is
the problem that i wanted to address in
my phd and the vision that i started off
with was what if we have a swarm of
robots swarm of drones
kind of orchestrating this haptic
interaction
what if we could predict what the user
was interested in interacting with and
then
one of these drones would fly
look for either a 3d printed model or
some even everyday object that could be
used as proxy for that virtual object
and presented to the user so that when
the user interacts with virtual content
they have a physical object a physical
surface to interact with
so i
i want to talk about one application of
where this could be useful for example
if you're doing some e-commerce
application you want to buy some piece
of clothing it's important for you to be
able to kind of reach out feel the
texture of the material and pick up that
object and feel its weight and and have
those types of kind of haptic feedback
in your interactions
so i set out to make this happen i first
started with just one drone so this is a
racing quadcopter that i've enclosed in
a meshed cage so it's safe to interact
with you're not gonna uh hurt yourself
hopefully
and i integrated this with the vr system
so with the virtual shopping experience
that i showed you earlier where we were
able to track the user's headset their
hand the drone and then depending on
which parts of the virtual scene we
could render physically with the drone
we would send waypoints to the drone to
fly to that position
but when it came to actually
implementing this and trying it out with
users we ran into
a lot of issues
the main one being the position accuracy
of the drone became a huge problem
as you can see here the person
interacting is not able to see the drone
itself so if the drone is not positioned
precisely where it needed to be in space
then no haptic interaction would happen
and this problem is not really unique to
the system or this haptic system
it's kind of
it happens across a range of haptic
devices so haptic devices include
controllers that i showed you earlier in
this talk
there could be haptic gloves
or encountered type haptech devices this
is a family of devices that
the drone actually falls within this
category but traditionally they've been
these
grounded robotic arms that move around
in space and present themselves to the
user whenever they encounter a surface
and what's great about them is that you
don't have to hold a controller or wear
anything but you're still presented with
a real physical surface to interact with
and all of these devices have
limitations for example
the accuracy in terms of how they're
positioned in space or where they
provide the haptic sensation could not
be
as accurate as we would want it to be
there could be speed
speed limitations where there may be
delays in the haptic rendering or the
speed of the robot moving around may not
be sufficient to support fast
interactions
and finally the resolution of the haptic
rendering could also
not be sufficient in that
we
might not be able to render very
detailed surfaces
so in my work
i draw on this insight that our
perception is not perfect so we don't
need these haptic devices to be perfect
and to demonstrate what i mean by our
perception is not
perfect i'm going to ask you all to try
to touch your fingers
together your index finger above your
head without looking at it
i see a lot of
kind of
not successful attempts
and this is an example of you relying on
your sense of proprioception the forces
in your arms to tell you where your
finger is in space and not having enough
information to do this correctly
and so what i'm trying to
convey here is that we don't need to
make these haptic systems really complex
and expensive when our perception is not
perfect and i hope to demonstrate this
in my work
and
what i do is that i argue that we can
leverage the limits of our perception to
make these devices appear as if they
work better than they actually do so
today i'll be talking to you about three
main projects the first one i'll go back
to
the project where i use drones for
haptics in vr and i'll talk to you about
how i leveraged a user's limitation of
users perception to make these drones
appear as if they were accurately
positioned in space even though they
weren't
in the second project i'll talk about
a different haptic device a tabletop
robot that we used for haptics and i'll
talk about how i used physio haptic
illusions
to make these devices appear as if they
work they were faster and moving faster
in space than they actually are
and in the third project
i use the shape display for haptics a
shape display is a matrix of actuated
pins that go up and down and they can
render different 2.5 d surfaces and i'll
talk about how i used illusions to make
these surfaces appear as if they were
higher resolution than they actually are
so i will use this slide as my outline
for the talk i'll walk you through these
three projects we which use illusions
for creating this sort of realistic
haptic rendering and then in the second
part of my talk i'll talk about how by
trading off the sense of realism we
actually can gain even more benefits and
can make
interactions uh better and give people
extend people's abilities so i'll
present an example of the sort of beyond
real interaction in the context of
locomotion and present a higher level
framework for talking about and
describing
these sort of interactions
so in my work i hope to demonstrate that
by understanding the limits of human
sensory integration and motor control we
can design effective vr interactions
that can create the illusion of improved
haptic sensation and extend users
abilities beyond what is possible in the
real world
so i'll start off by talking more about
the drone project going back to the
system that i described earlier so in
this project
we were able to create that kind of safe
to touch meshed drone we were able to
add
magnets around the drone so we could
attach different fabrics to it we could
attach 3d printed props to the drone and
also the drone itself could land and act
as kind of a passive box or prop for the
user to grasp and move around
so you might be thinking would people
even feel comfortable
being that close to a drone and touching
it and moving it around so this is what
we studied before doing this project was
um
trying uh to learn more about this so we
ran a user study with 24 participants
this was uh between uh sorry within
subjects study design so our users
interacted sorry it was a between
subject study design so our users half
of them um interacted with a normal
drone and the other half interacted with
an earlier version early earlier
prototype of our safe to touch drone
this was an elicitation study meaning
that we gave people visual prompts to
accomplish certain tasks but we didn't
tell them how to do those tasks and we
found that more than half of our
participants in the safe to touch drone
condition actually instinctively when
really close to the drone picked it up
touched it in order to kind of make it
take off or go further or come closer to
them but in the other condition with the
normal drone most people used voice
commands or mid
kind of hand gestures to make the drone
land or take off so this was encouraging
for us to know that maybe people are
okay
once you have kind of that mesh cage
around the drone to be that close
with the drone interacting with it
through touch
so let's return to
the problem we were having with this
drone ideally what we wanted was for the
drone to be positioned exactly at the
contact point where we were able to
provide the haptic sensation
but in reality what happened because of
the mesh cage and all the props that we
had attached to the drone was that there
was a slight offset
of how closely we were able to get the
drone position in space and more
problematically sometimes the drone
drifted away from where it needed to be
so this is what we were trying to kind
of address and fix in our interaction
and we were inspired by this work um
that was presented on haptech
retargeting so in this project
researchers used one passive cube to
represent three virtual cubes by kind of
creating this sort of haptic illusion
and this is a really cool trick once you
try it you'll once you take off your
headset you're really surprised to see
there was only one physical physical
cube in front of you and it's a really
nice kind of magic trick but in order to
take it from a passive block
from the user sitting at a very specific
distance from the object we had to kind
of go back and think about how does it
actually work why does it work and how
do we take that and apply it to a system
where the user is moving around the
drone is not the static object but also
moving around and how can we apply the
sort of illusion
on the go
so we looked at how the brain plans and
control controls movement so imagine you
want to reach out and touch an object
what happens is that
in the brain your intent is converted to
motor command signals
this is sent to your body which results
in your arm moving forward but this
movement is subject to noise uh
unpredictable changes in the environment
and other factors that the brain has to
kind of have a way of estimating how far
it went and and what happened in this
stage
and it does so by looking at the sensory
feedback that it receives you visually
see your hand moving space but also you
feel the forces in your muscles and
joints as you saw earlier
that gives you information about the
current state of your hand
the brain is then able to compare that
to where it expected your hand to be
and by you by kind of looking at the
difference it's able to correct and
compensate for the error and allow you
to actually reach and touch the goal
that you're trying to reach to
so what we did in this project was we
used
this knowledge of how we reach in space
and how we can kind of trick the brain
into
correcting its course
to improve the perceived position
accuracy of drones through a dynamic
version of this haptic retargeting that
i showed you earlier
so what we did is as the user reached
out to touch the drone or the contact
point if the drone drifted away we would
offset gradually their hand in the
opposite direction so what would happen
is that the user is getting visual
information about what happened and as a
result
will try to move their hand further left
to compensate for this error
so the outcome is that the user ends up
making contact in the real world with
the drone at a slightly different
position than where their virtual hand
is positioned in the in the virtual
system and if this difference is small
enough they don't even notice that
they're doing this because it's
happening so gradually and that and the
offset is not large enough
and the reason that this works is that
we have different sensory signals that
we're using
but not all of them are as reliable and
certain as the other ones so you tried
this earlier where you weren't quite
able to touch your fingers now i'm going
to ask that you do this in front of you
where you can use your sense of vision
i see that most people
i see one person that wasn't successful
but
most people i feel like we're able to do
this and that's because your sense of
vision is a lot more reliable and less
noisy than your sense of proprioception
in terms of giving you information about
where your hand is in space and your
brain knows this so when there's a
conflict in sensory information it
actually weighs your visual information
over your proprioception and kind of
ignores what it feels through the
muscles and this is called the visual
dominance effect
so by using this sort of dynamic haptic
retargeting we were able to make this
drone appear as if it was positioned
accurately in space by kind of
compensating for this position and
accuracy gradually throughout our
interaction
so we had
nine participants come into our lab and
interact with this system
all of them were successful in terms of
reaching the textile or reaching the
object but we also uncovered a lot of
kind of failure cases and limitations
where this haptic retargeting was not as
successful as we had hoped
and and there were a few uh kind of
variables that influenced this the first
one was the speed of the user's hand if
people reached out really quickly
towards the the
contact point they were interested in
interacting with we didn't have enough
time to kind of gradually offset their
hand and same with the distance that
they had to this if they were really
close to the target we didn't have
enough kind of time and distance to
gradually offset their hand without them
noticing another variable was how the
drone was drifting if it moved really
rapidly or if it moved in different
directions it was hard for us to
gracefully add this kind of haptic
retargeting
whereas if it was kind of gradually
drifting in the same direction we were
very successful at kind of retargeting
the user's hand
so in the second project i want to talk
to you about we were able to kind of
take this understanding and
decide when it made sense to add haptic
retargeting and when it didn't
so i will talk to you about this project
which was led by eric gonzalez who's
defending in a few months so you should
come to his defense as well
but in this project we used a
tabletop robot instead of the drones for
haptics and so the user was interacting
with a control panel and different
buttons and knobs were
placed on this robot that could move
around
and the problem here was that the robot
was not fast enough
to kind of keep up with the user's
interactions
as they were kind of trying to touch
different buttons on the control panel
so we were trying to use
these haptic retargeting techniques to
improve the perceived speed of these
tabletop robots
so the first thing that we did was we
looked at
how the user was their gaze pattern and
their hand velocity to be able to
predict where we think they were going
to touch
then we used existing models of
end to end kind of goal-directed reach
to be able to predict how long it would
take um for the user to arrive there so
we use their hand velocity profile to
estimate the arrival time of their
finger to that target position
we also knew the limitations of our
robot we knew how fast it could move so
we were able to predict how close it was
possible for it to get to that target
position during that time window
and so by having this information we
were able to gradually add this haptic
retargeting and allow the user to kind
of meet the robot halfway so they were
able to make contact with the virtual
button they were interested in in the
virtual world but in the physical world
their hand was making contact with the
robot at a slightly different position
and so by adding this predictive layer
we were able to have more information
about how long we have to add this
retargeting and how far the dis distance
between the goal and where we could get
the robot to was and if that was more
than where we thought people would
notice the illusion we would choose not
to apply any haptic retargeting so we
were able to say these are the cases
where this would work and these are the
cases where it makes sense to just
accept the fact that we might have the
robot kind of arrive with a delay
so now i want to switch gears to a third
project so the first two that i talked
about was more around kind of reaching
out to touch an object and now i want to
talk about once you arrive at that kind
of
contact area what how can we use these
sort of haptic illusions to make the the
renderings appear um as if they were
working better so
in this
project we used a shape display which is
a matrix of actuated pins that can go up
and down and they can render different
kind of 2.5 d surfaces for people to
interact with so this sort of haptic
interaction is called contour following
so you've already arrived at the surface
and you're kind of exploring that
surface
and the problem here as you can see is
that the shape display is relatively at
low resolution and the reason for that
is every single pin has a motor that's
actuating it up and down and when you
try to miniaturize these
motors they get really expensive so we
were thinking of how can we use these
kind of haptic illusions to make these
surfaces appear as if they were higher
resolution instead of kind of increasing
the complexity and cost of the device
itself
so we tried two methods that i will talk
to you about today the first one we call
angle redirection so here you can see
that i'm rendering a line at an angle
and the pins don't really line up that
nicely it's very uneven for me to kind
of trace that line
it's really kind of like a rasterization
problem of kind of getting that onto the
shape display
so what we do instead is render a
horizontal line and apply the same kind
of redirection trick that i showed you
earlier but in the context of the user's
finger
so that they visually see the same line
at an angle but physically they're
following a horizontal line and this
this really helped kind of have the pins
lined up really nicely and have kind of
a smooth
surface to interact with so we wanted to
see how far we could push this because
as you can imagine if the angle of the
line is at really large you might start
to really feel the forces in your arms
that would give this information away
that that we're applying an illusion and
kind of warping the space
so we ran a user study to find this kind
of detection threshold of what angle
we could how far we could take this
interaction
we used the method of constant stimuli
meaning that we gave people a lot of
repeated samples and some of the samples
had no illusion so we were rendering the
line exactly at an angle that they were
visually seeing in vr
and some of them had an illusion so
visually people were
kind of following a line at an angle but
in the physical world they were
following a horizontal line
and we gave people
very extreme versions of these two to
make sure that they understood what we
meant by an illusion
and what we meant by no illusion and
then we did the study of a method of
constant stimuli where they saw many
repeated samples
for different angles and we asked them
if we were using an illusion or not so
it was kind of a yes or no
answer
and this is the data from that study
from 19 participants that we fit a
psychometric curve
so the x-axis is the angles that we've
tried so we tried 5 10 25 35 and 45
degrees
the y-axis is the ratio of answers for
the same participant in terms of how
many what percentage they were able to
recognize that we were applying an
illusion so you can see at the beginning
uh people thought we weren't applying an
illusion even though all these data
points had an illusion and later on they
were able to kind of pick up on the more
we increased the angle they noticed that
we were applying the solution
so this point um here is at 50 so 0.5
ratio this is kind of the point where
people start are starting to just notice
that we are doing something so half of
the time they say we were using an
illusion half of the time they didn't
across these repeated samples so it's
kind of
like a guessing
and
75 75 or 0.75 ratio is uh normally used
in these kind of psychological
psychometrics tests as the detection
threshold of this is the point where
most people can tell you confidently
that um we are applying an illusion and
we found that this was around 50 degrees
for for our example
so we wanted to run a second study where
we didn't tell people what we were doing
we didn't tell them that we were
applying an illusion and we wanted to
stick below this kind of 50 degree angle
and see if it actually helped to make
the shape display
be better at kind of rendering haptics
so we ran a second study where this time
we used
the
method of two alternative force choice
tasks so we did told people that we had
two different shape displays even though
we only had one shape display half one
sample had the case with the illusion so
we were rendering a line at an angle but
they were touching a horizontal line and
in the other sample they were
kind of following the line at the angle
that it was
and we randomized the order of these two
and we asked them which which shape
display they thought was a higher
resolution
smoother and which one they preferred
again they didn't see that this was the
same shape display they thought we had
two different shape displays
i'm going to show you the results for 40
degrees which is the highest angle that
we tried below those kind of illusion
thresholds
this is aggregated data across all 19
participants across all repeated samples
and the majority of people thought that
the case with the illusion was the
higher resolution shape display the one
that was smoother as they interacted
with it and the one that they preferred
and we found the similar results for the
other angles that we tried like 10 20
and 30 degrees so by applying this
illusion we were able to make the shape
display appear as if it
worked better than it actually did
a second method that we tried was
scaling up so here instead of rendering
a line i'm rendering the semi-sphere and
as you can see the surface is kind of
uneven there are only a few pins in this
area so it's not a very pleasant
experience your finger almost gets
caught in these pins
but what we can do instead is we can
scale up the rendering on the shape
display and change the speed of the
user's finger as they're tracing the
surface so if you're familiar with the
concept of control to display ratio in
in the mouse when you're interacting
with the computer this is what we're
doing we're basically changing the user
cd ratio of their virtual finger as
they're tracing the surface so we're
able to create this illusion of
more pins per area
we did the same kind of two-step study
for this i won't get into the details
but again we did these repeated samples
where people experienced some without
the illusion and some with and we drew
the psychometric curve and we found that
given the specific dimensions of our
shape display we were able to scale up
the rendering butter by around 1.9 times
of the original
we ran the same follow-up study where
we gave people two shape displays even
though it was the same shape display and
one just had the illusion we asked them
with which one the case with the
illusion or not was the one that they
preferred thought was higher resolution
and smoother
so i'll show you the highest scale
factor that we tried which was 1.8
below that kind of threshold of when
people started to notice that we were
kind of changing the speed of their
finger
we found again that majority of people
aggregated across all samples and all
participants
thought the case with illusion was
higher resolution smoother and what they
preferred
so in the other interaction i told you
that for every angle the angle
redirection worked pretty effectively
but for scaling up we didn't find that
at lower scale factor it worked as well
so this is the result for 1.2 times the
scale factor and as you can see we the
the results were not as strong and this
makes sense the more you scale up the
more pins per area you end up with and
so people feel like that surface is
higher resolution smoother and also what
they prefer
so in this project
i showed you two
kind of haptic illusion interactions one
was angle redirection and the other one
was scaling up that helped us improve
the perceived resolution of shape
displays
and this allowed us to kind of have
smooth surfaces as we did renderings and
also gave us a chance to render more
details by scaling up the the
interaction
so i talked to you
about these three projects that use
illusions for realistic haptic rendering
and
really what we're doing in this project
is that we're remapping users movements
in vr so if i kind of place that across
this axis of how true to life
the interaction is which is known as the
verity continuum
if we were to do what most vr
interactions would be where you try to
render users hand exactly where the real
hand is you will end up on kind of this
side of this continuum where these are
known as reality-based interactions
you're trying to do your best to render
users hands exactly where they they are
positioned so what we were doing in
these three projects is that we're
slightly offsetting users hand position
to allow us to create these sort of
illusions that make these devices appear
as if they worked better and you can
imagine we could do other things that
would fall in this category we could
maybe extend the user's arm ever so
slightly if your virtual arm is slightly
longer you're probably not going to
notice to some extent
and these interactions
work great for kind of maintaining this
idea of realistic interaction but also i
realized that we were so caught up and
focused on
identifying these thresholds of when do
these illusions break and making sure
that we stuck below these thresholds to
maintain that kind of realistic
interaction
so in the second part of my talk i'll
talk about what we gain when we trade
off this realism and when we accept the
fact that people's perception is
adaptable and flexible and they can
learn to operate in really warped spaces
where your hand may be totally somewhere
else and you can still be trained and
learn how to operate in that warp space
and you could also learn to have a
different body representation where your
arm could extend much further you can
grab really far objects and and that you
could learn how to use that that
interaction
so in the second part of my talk i'll
talk about these
interactions which we've called beyond
real interactions so i'll be referring
to real world and real interaction a lot
and i just want to clarify that i don't
mean that there is this objective real
world that's separate from the user's
objective
subjective mental model but i'm really
just referring to what people can
perceive through their sensory
information
without the use of technology
so i'll talk about how we can use these
beyond real interactions for extending
our abilities beyond what we can do in
the real world and i'll talk about um an
example of this in the context of
locomotion and then i'll present a kind
of like a higher level conceptual
framework
and locomotion refers to kind of walking
around in space and this has only been
possible in the past few years where now
we have untethered vr headsets that
allow us to kind of walk around in vr as
well but if you think about walking is a
very slow form of locomotion and we can
do so much better in vr if we kind of
accept the fact that we could remap
users movements
so this started from my internship back
in 2018 at microsoft research where we
were looking at how we can make people
walk more efficiently in vr
and this technique that we explored was
called i'm a giant or kind of turning
into a giant so basically we were
scaling up people's body representation
which as a result allowed us to let them
walk much faster so here i'm walking 10
times faster in vr but by kind of
embodying this
avatar that's 10 times my body size
and we ran a user study and we found
that this was really easy for people to
use we had these um targets that they
had to go to and stop and we found that
they were able to
stop really accurately at those target
positions they felt stable and they
didn't experience motion sickness
we also tried uh an example of this sort
of beyond real locomotion interaction
from the literature known as the seven
league boots in this interaction you
maintain your body scale but every step
that you take your displacement is
amplified along your walking direction
so it has the same effect
and here i'm showing that at 10x speedup
where every step takes you 10 times
further further but
you kind of maintain your body scale
and when we tried this with our
participants we had 18 participants
within subject study design trying both
of these interactions we found that
people felt unstable they felt motion
sickness and they weren't actually able
to stop accurately at these target
positions that we had
and so these are example two kind of
sample design points in a really large
design space of what kind of
transformations we could have tried to
have this effect of
effect efficient walking in vr
and what we did was we tried them out we
had this empirical evaluation but here
what i want to argue is that we need to
have ways of more systematically
investigating these designs in addition
to kind of this empirical approach
because this design space is so large
and i'd argue that in order to do so we
need to understand perception and action
so how we perceive sensory information
and perceive the world and how in turn
we act and move in the world
so now i want to return to kind of this
diagram that i had in terms of how our
brain plans and controls movement and
more explicitly position vr interactions
in this context
so
vr really what it's doing is that it's
intercepting all the sensory signals so
when you move your hand forward
in the real world this movement is being
sensed and tracked and then transformed
into some virtual rendering
and so the brain is receiving sensory
information from both the real world and
the virtual system
you feel your joints and muscles in your
real arm but visually you're seeing your
virtual avatar's arm moving in vr
so one way we can describe beyond real
interactions is that they apply a
transformation to this movement that is
not a one-to-one mapping
so and this really results in a sensory
conflict
you feel the forces
in your real hand your real arm
that give you information about where
your real hand is but in the virtual
world
you're getting
completely conflicting information of
where your um
uh virtual hand is and this discrepancy
is not subtle like the previous
interactions that i showed you where you
could kind of ignore it and resolve it
but you actually notice and have access
to this conflicting information
so in a recent work
we provide kind of a conceptual
framework using this sensory motor lens
to be able to describe vr interactions
that go beyond what's possible in the
real world that allows us to think about
what is the sensory information that the
user is receiving both from the real
world and the virtual system
across different
sensory systems and how that affects the
internal model and is influenced by the
internal model in return
so i want to use kind of this framing to
go back to the two examples of
locomotion techniques that i talked to
you about to kind of describe
what kind of predictions we could have
had
in the case of i'm a giant you're kind
of turning into a giant you're walking
around this miniature world this might
be an experience you've had when you
went to an amusement park or
when you were a child you had this
experience of having a different kind of
scale towards your surroundings but also
you have visual information that is able
to provide insight to your internal
model so you can predict what will
happen when you take a step further when
you take a step you know and expect the
outcome of that and you know how far
you're going to get so this there's no
kind of
unexpected outcome in the internal model
but going back to the seven link booths
what's happening here is that first of
all there's no visual information you
everything looks normal you have no
expectations of what your movements will
do until after you take a step and
realize that your emotion is being
amplified
but also when you start walking from the
real world you're getting
information through your inner ear of
your vestibular system telling you what
your linear acceleration is but visually
you're seeing the virtual world move at
a very different linear acceleration
and this is kind of this is something
that the brain cannot predict it cannot
understand how this could be possible
and depending on individual differences
this is known to cause motion sickness
especially at really high gains like 10
times going 10 times faster
so by kind of thinking about these
different sensory signals and how they
interact and integrate we're able to
have more intuitions about which which
of these design will work better than
the other before we actually implement
them and go out and try it out with
different people
so today in my talk
i talked to you about three projects um
i used haptic retargeting to improve the
perceived accuracy of drones when they
were used for haptics then i'll talk
talked about how we use these techniques
for improving the perceived speed of
tabletop robots and talked about how we
could add a predictive layer in order to
kind of decide when it would make sense
for us to apply these illusions versus
not
and then i talked about kind of more of
a haptic contour following task where
once you arrive at a
haptic device we can also use these
haptic illusions to make
these devices appear as if they were
able to render haptic sensations at a
higher resolution so these three
projects
they used illusions to improve
the haptic devices performance and
create this kind of realistic haptic
rendering in the second half of my talk
i talked about these beyond real
interactions that allowed us to extend
our abilities
and provided an example of this
interaction and also a kind of a
conceptual framework to how to think
about them and move towards kind of
having more predictive models
in the future
so in terms of what i hope i was able to
demonstrate in my talk i showed that
illusory interactions can be used to
improve haptic devices i showed these
implemented in three different haptic
device systems and also
did user evaluation of this these
systems to not only demonstrate how they
work and find the limitations of the
haptic interactions but also find out
more about limitations of our perception
and different kind of sensory thresholds
i also described beyond real
interactions and how they can be used to
extend our abilities beyond what we can
do
in the physical world
i presented a conceptual framework for
us to think about haptic
virtual reality interactions in the
context of how the brain plans and
controls movement and use that to be
able to understand sensory conflict and
different sensory information that we're
receiving from different sources
and i also presented a user evaluation
of two different beyond real
interactions and talked about how the
framework could be extended to
potentially have predictive power in the
future
so through remapping users movements in
these two kind of two parts we were able
to not only overcome the current
limitations of
vr technology more specifically haptic
technology but we were able to kind of
overcome the limitations of our real
world interactions and what we can do in
the real world
so in terms of future work and open
challenges
i think
as as a field we're trying to design
usable vr interactions and we need to
have ways of evaluating these
interactions more systematically so i
think we need to move towards kind of
building tools that integrate our
understand our understand understanding
of human perception and sensory motor
control to allow us to
have this sort of predictive power
before we go out and try it out with
users and i think simulation is going to
play a really important role in how we
try different alternatives in advance
also something that i didn't really talk
about in my talk today is the importance
of individual differences people have
different sensory motor abilities but
also different perceptual sensitivities
and all of these influence motor control
and i think we need to have better ways
of hopefully while maintaining privacy
capturing users behaviors and using our
understanding of sensory motor control
to be able to adapt interactions to
those individual people
all the uh projects i talked to you
about were presented in this context of
virtual reality but also another open
challenge is how do we take those
findings and uh take them to a space
like augmented reality where we don't
have as much control over
kind of what sensory information the
user is receiving what they're attending
to and they're kind of going on about
their lives and how do we handle that
kind of complexity of the real world and
the uncertainty that comes with that
these are the credits for the artworks
that i used in my talk and with that i'm
happy to answer any questions
[Applause]
yeah so one thing i'm curious is in the
the three haptic illusion papers you
showed especially with like drones these
are noisy devices right and i'm
wondering if you ever saw an effect
where like literally the noise of the
drone affected someone's perception of
the illusion of the world of the virtual
or the physical reality yeah that's a
great question i don't know if people on
zoom were able to hear but the question
was around the noise of these devices
specifically the drones
so in all of these studies we use noise
cancelling headphones and that is not
very unusual most people in vr will be
wearing headphones anyways um and what
is nice is that the frequency of this
drone
uh kind of noise is consistent and so
headphones are really good at kind of
eliminating that
i can't say that people totally weren't
able to hear it but it definitely helped
a lot
another thing that you didn't mention is
the wind and the kind of airflow from
the drone so people definitely noticed
that especially when the drone was close
to them
and what was surprising from the
findings was that people kind of liked
that aspect of the interactions because
it gave them this kind of ambient sense
of where the drone was relative to them
so without having to pay attention to it
they felt safe when they weren't feeling
the noise or wind and when it when they
expected it to be close to them that was
kind of reassuring in terms of what they
expected from the interaction so
something to think about for the future
but in the meantime it had this kind of
uh
surprising effect than what we expected
yes
okay uh yeah so um
hi
congratulations chris dude
your dad was a graduate student of mine
decades ago
i wanted my i won't specify the number
of decades
the question i have is this
um
do you think someday we can
wear something on our fingers
like a small
device
that induces the sense of touch rather
than relying on physical objects that we
have to move around
yeah that's a great question yeah so
there are a variety of other haptic
devices other than the encounter type
haptic devices that i focused on
in my work that include kind of wearable
devices that use vibro tactile actuators
and not physical sensations and other
things and there are there is actually a
lot of work on using haptic
illusions to make these kind of
vibrations and other uh sensations
appear differently than they are so uh
yeah definitely that's um
something that people are working on i
think why i'm excited about these type
of encounter type haptics is that they
don't require you to wear anything and
so you could kind of go on about your
day and interact with things the way you
do and and still
be able to interact with these haptic
devices
thank you so much for your question
yeah thank you
um when you were on the first one on the
accuracy part where they were trying to
hold the clothes or hanger
uh do you um sort of when you hold like
a hanger itself because it that's sweet
in in the actual stuff uh do you
actually like press harder on on the
user's finger or something
because it's you know it's carrying
something so that's a great question
yeah so drones definitely have
limitations in terms of what kind of
force feedback they can provide um and
especially kind of moving vertically
there's certain kind of forces that you
could apply and because of that um
yeah i i can't say we had like a lot of
control in terms of how much weight
rendering we were able to do
but
the illusions that i talked about could
apply to all these different devices
that could be used for a different
uh sort of haptic sensation so we were
kind of focusing mainly on arriving at a
physical object feeling the texture but
we didn't have so much
ability in terms of rendering different
force uh forces and weights and
stiffness yeah
yeah drones are under action yeah
we have another question on zoom
hi can you hear me yes
great um i'm just wondering like yeah
like i think maybe like a follow-up
question is
you know
how would you be able to feel these
kinds of physical objects
while you were in the virtual world
without you necessarily having to
interface to say that the physical world
first right because a lot of the
devices that you have you have to you
know put your hand on the object first
before you start the experience
yeah i'm not sure if i totally followed
your question
um are you asking if we could do haptic
rendering without a physical device
i'm saying like how could you in more
seamlessly integrate the physical
devices
into the virtual reality without you
know having the conscious perception
that this is a physical device
you know actually doing things
yeah does that make sense
or not yeah i think so yeah i think
there are a range of haptic devices you
could have so you could have these kind
of encounter type physical surfaces that
may be suitable for certain applications
but then you can move into more kind of
wearable vibro tactile devices if you're
kind of only looking for physical cues
um and and there's also kind of work on
uh using electrical
muscle stimulation as a way of kind of
uh
triggering your neurons instead of kind
of interacting with physical world so
there's definitely a range
and i think they'll make sense in
different contexts depend on depending
on the interactions and the applications
of vr
thank you
great
yep i i don't know who
my first
but yeah the person at the back
yep
um yeah i noticed a lot of the examples
people were reaching out to touch with
one finger and i was wondering were they
instructed to do that or did any of the
illusions function differently if people
were to like reach out with an open palm
and try to kind of do this motion yeah
that's a great question so
the case with the um
the first project the drone people are
not instructed to touch with a finger
and we tried to kind of estimate their
uh basically we were tracking the back
of their hand and we had enough surface
area in terms of textile that we were
able to kind of
provide that
texture regarding of like regardless of
how many fingers they used
but the example with the shape display
was very much kind of like one finger
interactions that's a great question to
think about
what happens when you use your full hand
kind of following a contour
and my my hypothesis would be that
having more fingers and you having
information about the relative positions
of your finger could kind of give you
more information in terms of
what is happening in in the real world
so that is something that i haven't
studied in the context of kind of
redirecting your finger but that's a
great question
[Music]
yeah thank you so much
we have another question on zoom
that i came up with so for the beyond
rail interaction framework you mentioned
it can be used for evaluation i wonder
uh what how would you imagine the
workflow would be
for other researchers or practitioner to
use your model to design their own
beyond rail interactions is that is that
possible is there any recommended
workflow
yeah and so in our recent kai paper we
do like a walk-through example of how it
could be applied and we have more
examples in the appendix where
people can kind of break down their
interaction design thinking about what
sensory information people are receiving
from the physical world and the real
world and how they might integrate
what i would say though is that i think
the takeaway from that paper
was that there is a lot that we know
about human sensory motor control and
perception but there's a lot we don't
know especially when it comes to
applying them into a kind of open-ended
interaction design as opposed to kind of
these control neuroscience or psychology
studies that people have done before and
so they're they're all there are a lot
of gaps in terms of how much we can uh
leverage prior work in uh having more
predictive power and and we try to kind
of um ex
expand on these open research questions
uh in the future as well but yeah thank
you so much
that makes sense thanks thank you
um
so i'm curious about like your you know
the open question that you put out the
ar one
you can't fool people because they can
see you know they are the illusions like
these types and uh people don't use
controllers in ar
so what would be the
ways to enrich the interaction like in
ar yeah that's a great question so
i wouldn't so there you're totally right
in that we don't have the ability to
totally block a certain sense and
replace it with whatever visual
renderings there but there is way ways
in which you could overwrite some
information and so the example that i
showed with
you having an a longer arm this is
there's a paper from kai from a few
years ago where they tried this in ar
and you can imagine you could have an
extension of your arm in ar that allows
you to kind of interact with virtual
objects that are at a distance so there
are both ways in which you can extend
the kind of real world
views of of what people are seeing but
also there's ways you can kind of trick
them in terms of what you overlay
visually on top of the physical world
and how
i think perception will become really
important in that con context as well
using light and shade and using these
illusions in terms of how you're
rendering virtual content
and also vision is not the only sense
right you could have auditory illusions
and using audio as a way of kind of
giving
ambient information to people as they're
interacting in the in the physical world
and in other senses as well
but yeah that's a great kind of open
research space i think
okay so we should wrap it up and give us
another question